[Musique]
allez les amis chanteurs ne pas cumuler
et tac tac tac tac tac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors dis dans mes bras vous avez un
chat aussi j'adore ces personnes aient
regardé celles ci sont ceux qui je vais
rouler
je
salut alors l'équipe la plus gentil du
monde regarder devant ma porte en
récidive et décide d'en monter mais
c'est pas grave parce que c'est trop
longue à guérir du soulor
[Applaudissements]
à nos décideurs
c'est souvent de regarder où je suis
alors je check mccoach patricia
bertapelle que je suis avec mon
mécanicien
nous sommes à super besse et profonde
rose et là je suis sur ma superbe petite
voiture on est en train de faire tous
les réglages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mis au maquillage
non traitée peut aujourd'hui si un
déguisement pour enrico macias moi je
suis un fidèle qui pète loi ici il pleut
blanche avec riis aux poires christophe
lui pour le coup je lui laisse lui va
être premier moi je vais deuxième
ces champions il est toujours mieux
quand on paye tout arrive mon bonne
chance
bisous peut-être trop contente d'être
avec maxime
ou alors en faisant les deuxième
qualificative c'était mieux parce que
j'ai pas fait deux tête à queue donc
voilà de vous on attend avec impatience
la deuxième finale
exact un bon run deux tours sans appel
faute et devant claudio cavina
dégueulasse et la statue à paris la
mairie de la ville a fait savoir qu'elle
attendait le feu vert de tous les
héritiers du chanteur une sollicitation
à laquelle laëtitia n'a pour le moment
pas souhaité les fonds débloqués mon âge
il y en a pour tous les goûts
le rapport
[Musique]
votre alsace sur les fabophiles
collectionneurs de fèves bon pour cette
dernière
je vais être en compétition avec sacha
avec sacha compétition de blessures
graves
après boy who
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]